buckle up we begin with a fox news alert
it will take
well the next 10 hours to give you all
the news we have we're trying to break
it down as best we can
we have two breaking news stories we are
tracking tonight first just moments ago
we received definitive evidence that the
corrupt
the compromise congenital liar that guy
that i've been telling you about adam
schiff he has
willfully been deceiving you we the
american people for years
transcripts he's been hiding from the
house intel committee's witch hunt into
russian
quote interference have finally been
released but thanks to
the director of national intelligence uh
yeah
and attorney general barr adam schiff is
being
exposed as being a bigger liar than we
even thought
also documents revealing bombshell new
information on
what barack obama knew about deep state
spying
he knew a lot more than we ever knew we
have those details coming
up also breaking tonight the department
of justice
and attorney general barr rightly have
dropped all charges against lieutenant
general
michael flynn and that means soon his
nearly four year
nightmare and ordeal will be over and
only if the presiding federal judge
emmett sullivan agrees with the doj's
motion
flynn was we've told you for years and
is an innocent man he's an honorable man
a 33-year veteran who served his country
with distinction
but because of his support for president
trump he like the president
many other people around the president
they were subjected to
years of total hell by a
corrupt group of dirty cops to quote joe
digenova
first time he said it on the show i
flinched they're dirty cops
all my family was in law enforcement
that's not how we believe cops act or
fbi acts and you know what it was only
one percent not the rank and file
what happened to general flynn is just
the tip of the iceberg
we're going to lay out a comprehensive
timeline of this corruption we will
detail the very
real crimes that we believe were
committed by these few
high-ranking bad actors we'll call out
what is the media mob
the acting cheerleaders for government
malfeasance
they were going after phony stories like
russia collusion and ukraine quid pro
quo's
ignored hillary's dirty russian dossier
russian disinformation from the get-go
they ignored you're not getting the
million unless you fire the prosecutor
paying my inexperience on millions
just to go after donald trump it has
been a two-tiered
justice system two-tiered coverage in
your media mob the attorney general
is now speaking out we have part of that
interview he gave earlier tonight
flynn's attorney sydney powell will join
us the great one mark levin will weigh
in
and later wow thank god she's free we
will have an exclusive interview with
shelly luther
she was the salon owner that was told
you apologized to the government are you
going to jail
what far left-wing judge put her behind
bars
slapped her with a seven thousand dollar
fine because she wanted her employees to
be able to feed their kids
and she refused to apologize for trying
to feed her children and those that work
for her
she's a hero for standing up to that
judge first we've got to address what is
the foundation of this great
republic what is it our constitution
liberty
justice equal justice under the law
equal application of our laws
people that abuse power people that are
corrupt the powerful tools of
intelligence misused
people with agendas in this case what
was an attempt at
stopping donald trump from being
president and then undoing
an election in other words they didn't
like the choice of
you we the people so they did everything
in their power
a lot of corrupt things and illegal
things to take donald trump down
they've tried ever since he was elected
and even before he was elected
shortly after the doj's announcement
lieutenant general flynn
he tweeted out this video of his
grandson it reminds us that there
are good people and that there is hope
and that sometimes
with good people in power justice can
and will prevail take a look
i
a deleted states of america
and to the populace well legit
stash one nation
under god
all right maybe you could teach joe
biden how to say things
i don't know but he got it right good
job looks like
general flynn's grandson understands the
core american principle better than some
of these corrupt bad actors
who tried to persecute his grandfather
let's take a look at how we got here
let's start in early january 2017 before
president trump was even sworn into
office the fbi determined flynn had done
nothing
wrong nothing in fact crossfire comey's
crossfire hurricane
investigation found no evidence of
collusion from anyone associated with
donald trump
thanks to a recent document discovery we
learned that by january of 2017 there
was no
derogatory material on flynn in the
fbi's files
zero in the defense intel agency files
zero derogatory material as it relates
to material in the cia files
and we know that by january 4 2017 the
case against flynn
was supposed to be closed that is until
the
fbi leadership on the infamous seventh
floor got involved
that same day peter struck plea don't
close out the case
and then comes jim comey a few weeks
later fourth day into the trump
administration
strzok is asking quote what is our goal
truth admission or to get general flynn
to lie
so that then we can prosecute him and
get him fired or get him fired
those words should never come out of
anybody
in the fbi ever the goal should be
justice and truth always
that's not a question that he should
have ever asked fact that he asked it
and got answers is scary that quote
quite literally is the definition of a
perjury trap
but in jim comey's fbi well it was all
means to an
end january 24th mr higher loyalty
super patriot himself jim comey he
directed his agents to
ambush general flynn at the white house
and as he bragged about to take
advantage of the chaos in the white
house
something he wouldn't do in the obama
bush administrations or get away with
and push aside all due process which
would be
going through the white house general
counsel in other words
comey's disreputable right right-hand
man director
let's see deputy director mccabe well he
just told clinton oh you don't need a
lawyer
that was a lie too it was all a setup
and
comey sent them in and like the idiotic
pompous
jackass that jim comey bragged about
well he bragged about the whole dirty
trick
on camera think about this does this
sound like a guy that has a higher
loyalty to truth honor law enforcement
the constitution of the united states
because to me
he's the dirty cop that joe digenova
warned us about
you look at this white house now and
it's hard to imagine two fbi agents
ending up in the sit room how did that
happen
i sent them
um something we i
probably wouldn't have done or maybe
gotten away with in a more organized
investigation
a more organized administration in the
george w bush administration for example
or the obama administration
and in both of those administrations
there was process and so if the fbi
wanted to send agents into the white
house itself
to interview a senior official you would
work through the white house council and
there'd be discussions and approvals and
who would be there
and i thought it's early enough let's
just send a couple guys over
yeah you think that's funny jim really
this is a 33-year veteran of this
country jim comey really
you don't need a lawyer you're sending
him in you're setting him up
you're doing things you wouldn't do to
anybody else wow
jim comey was using the logan act
1799 law that nobody's ever been
prosecuted under
ever to squeeze lieutenant general flynn
nobody ever found guilty of violating
that obscure law since 1999
and get this the agents that conducted
the ambush they didn't think that flynn
was lying
we don't have the original 302 notes
that struck and paige are talking about
seemingly altering later on because in
search of a crime you got people like
strzok
and paige doing the bidding of comey and
mccabe they made significant revisions
to the initial 302
in other words they changed the
interview notes they set them up again
and by the way they invented the perjury
trap that's by saying you don't need a
lawyer
well what's our goal here do we want
them to lie we want to set him up for
perjury so he gets prosecuted
and all the while comey mccabe rod
rosenstein and others
they themselves premeditated fraud on
fisa court
heard that a lot from me over the last
three years despite knowing full well
that hillary's bought and paid for
dossier even the new york
toilet paper times figured out was
likely russian disinformation from the
beginning
yeah she paid for russia in appearance
and they used it
as the basis the bulk of information on
the fisa warrant applications oh by the
way we learned an awful lot in these
papers today about that we'll get to
that
and by the way that was to take away
carter page's civil liberties
and constitutional rights and in june of
2017
well into the trump administration
mccabe rosenstein
they signed off on the fourth pfizer
renewal the only problem is they knew
months earlier
that it was useless they had debunked it
they knew it wasn't true
they knew the sub source after three
interviews had said
nah still that's not accurate august 2nd
2017 you have
acting a.g rod rosenstein providing
robert mueller
with a letter detailing the scope of the
investigation
that scope consisted of a few dozen
baseless charges
and a few allegations totally unrelated
to
collusion the accusations against
general flynn
had previously been debunked by the fbi
in
early january premeditated fraud on a
fisa court they were worn before the
october 2016
fisa application we have in these papers
andrew mccabe admitting
yeah without we i don't know he actually
said i don't know if any of it's true
and then he also said without it they
never would have gotten the fisa
application approved
that was what in part guys like adam
schiff have been hiding from we
the people all this time that we found
out today the mueller probe
was always a political witch-hunt it was
a hoax
it was a conspiracy against donald trump
this was an attempted coup to undo
a duly elected president and take him
down
and lie about it the whole way that's
why they turned the screws on flynn
i'm looking at the tweets by idiots like
chief and nadler today
well he lied he lied well the fbi didn't
think he was lying
but when they finally threatened to put
his son in jail after he was bankrupt
and after he had to sell his house and
he had no more money left at that point
to pay the legal fees and they said
they're going to lock up the guy's son
uh where do i sign like the great
soldier he was he
dove on the sword to protect his family
that's not lying
that's prosecutorial misconduct that is
abuse of power
that is corruption at the highest levels
today the president
referred to it as treason take a
he was targeted by the obama
administration
and he was targeted in order to try and
take down a president
and what they've done is a disgrace i
hope a lot of people are going to pay a
big price
because they're dishonest crooked people
they're scum
and i say it a lot they're scum they're
human scum
this should never have happened in this
country the obama administration
justice department was a disgrace and
they got caught
they got caught very dishonest people
but much more than this
it's treason it's treason what they did
to general flynn
papadopoulos roger stone paul manafort
was all a means to an
end based on phony bought and paid for
russian lies and they knew they were
russian lies
well they didn't care that they ruined a
33-year veteran's life or his family's
life
these bad actors they wanted to undo
your election
your meaning we the american people at
all costs
naturally the mob and the media oh they
were cheering it on
wrongly every step of the way this is
just the tip of the iceberg let's take a
look
did flynn go rogue by the way when he
spoke to russia
well that would be a bigger scandal than
almost
anything we've ever seen in any other
presidential administration
oh breaking news abc news brian ross
is reporting michael flynn promised full
cooperation to the mueller team
and is prepared to testify that as a
candidate donald trump directed him
to make contact with the russians
next we're going to get back to michael
flynn's guilty plea today and what
that's well how it's made this a
historic day here in d.c
the fact is michael flynn betrayed his
country
michael flynn betrayed the nation
michael flynn did nothing wrong where
are the apologies where does he go to
get his good name back
where does he go to get his house back
how does he get his family how does he
get four years of his life back
because those idiots in the media mob
they've been lying
smearing slandering besmirching
character assassinating everybody and
anybody
just in their psychotic rage against
donald trump
like they're doing right now like they
do every day washington compost new york
toilet paper times
fake news cnn conspiracy tv ms dnc
they carried the water for all of the
lies conspiracy theories
every hoax every bad actor they
published every deceptive lie
and leak and they lied to purposely
misled the american people every second
every minute every hour of every day to
bludgeon
the president you we the people elected
not only is it a disservice to the
country they
too must be held accountable this is
dangerous what they have done
here they got awfully close to
succeeding
on a mountain of lies that they
perpetrated because they're too
lazy and they're too corrupt to search
for real truth
all of those so-called news outlets
missed the biggest
abuse of power corruption story they'd
ever have in their lifetime
and they peddled conspiracy theories in
the end we on this program
we were searching for truth and justice
we went our own path with our ensemble
team
and after a long wait finally this is
the beginning justice is coming
senator chuck grassley said that the
durham investigation
into the investigators will likely
result in prosecutions
jim comey tick-tock hope you're worried
tonight your corruption has been laid
bare for
all to see you i will say
that our friend joe digenova who made me
flinch on this program
because my family had a lot of police
officers my mom was a prison guard
my dad was a probation officer i had
cousins that were cops
there were two guys in my family that
were deity they made it to the fbi
there was a reverence for them unlike
any other family member
anyway tonight comey apparently sees
himself as a kind of an american hero
because he's so delusional on twitter
he's complaining about the doj
seeking the truth and dropping its case
against flynn
the doj has lost its way but career
people please stay
america needs you the country is hungry
for honest competent leadership
uh he's probably asking his fellow deep
staters to stick around hopefully he can
make a return
i don't think anyone on earth will be
taking any advice from the disgraced
fired fbi director
and soon if there's justice equal
justice
equal application well jim i warned you
a long time ago you have the right to
remain silent and i suggest you use it